i have to play a video for you today
that is out of this world cringe this is
giga cringe that's what the kids call it
and it really shows us how sort of
backwards like what counts as humor
is completely backwards in american
right-wing culture right now but it also
shows us hypocrisy and that's an
important part of this as well so let me
set it up for you there is a comedian
some say ann comedian and i'm completely
an historian i'm behind and comedian it
cannot be comedian jim brewer
he has become sort of a darling of the
right wing over
uh his commentary about the pandemic
because he was on tucker carlson
speaking out against vaccine mandates he
has moved shows around to try to
circumvent vaccination requirements we
had a clip of him making a total fool
out of himself on tucker carlson's show
about a month ago i have never found
this guy funny i used to hear him on the
howard stern show a decade ago two
decades ago and i always said this guy's
not funny i don't know why he's on i
didn't know anything about his politics
he has become even less funny and the
material i'm about to play for you i
watched this it gave me chills i had
chicken skin
from watching this cringe
so here's a clip of jim brewer
and this counts as comedy for the
american right wing folks and he's sort
of doing a bird impression now
hold on
that could be funny maybe i don't know
and the bird impression
is to mock people
who pay attention to scientists
specialists and doctors rather than i
guess right-wing media figures and
quacks and he does the bird impression
while saying things like fouchy
science and for me the notable part of
this is there have been unfunny
comedians for a long time that's not new
the most notable part is that they pan
to people in the audience this is at one
of these
reawaken america events
um and people are just losing their
minds laughing pointing laughing they're
in hysterics do these people not get out
of their house
and so for me that says way more about
the people who like this stuff brewer
hasn't been funny for decades but the
audience acting like this is the
vanguard of comedy is amazing so take a
look at the video you know what a
cockatoo is
cockatoo
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that's what everyone's become
little cockatoos staring at the screen
facts and figures facts and figures dr
fauci dr felty
ah
trust the science trust the science
uh specialist specialists numbers going
up numbers going up one missed two max
fascinated double
yeah so the and i apologize for showing
that to you the crowd just has never
seen anything this funny this is again
it's the reawaken america tour it's a
right-wing
tour it's like a circus it goes around
the country and it's a combination of
anti-vaxx coveted denial
i guess christianity and conspiracy
theories that's what it is and so
there's a bunch of stuff here the
hysterical crowd pointing and laughing
like it's just so
it's we've never seen anything this
funny do these people literally not
leave their houses like are you just
watching paint dry all day
that this
is what makes you laugh it's very very
strange or are you just so desperate for
something pretending to be comedy that
makes fun of the left to be funny that
you are willing to laugh at anything and
then here's the hypocrisy and i want to
make sure everybody understands this
jim brewer laughed
at science
specialists
numbers going up following data
when jim brewer's wife was sick with
cancer he went on the radio and he was
asked about it i don't remember if it
was opium anthony or one of those shows
and he said
we are going to the best specialist i
mean he he used the word in this clip he
laughs at listening to specialists
because it's coveted
when his wife was sick
he went to specialists and he said we're
going to we're finding the best
specialists
we're looking at the research and the
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
which we are now dismissing when it
comes to covid
we are looking at clinical trials we are
following the science when it came down
to his wife he wasn't doing this act he
was going to the exact professionals and
trusting the exact system that he now
ridicules you can find that segment if
you look for it oh i sirius xm is very
litigious with uh copyright but you can
find that segment so as usual
disgusting value going out there and
saying specialist oh oh fouchy
but he doesn't even really appear
to adhere to those very values
when the rubber meets the road gross and
by the way
the rights still can't do comedy nothing
has changed there folks we'll have this
clip up on our instagram make sure
you're following us there at david
pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be right back
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video